[Music]
for a century most western governments
are banned recreational drugs other than
alcohol and tobacco
but now there are signs of a change in
perception like the use of some
psychedelic drugs
actually be beneficial with me first of
all is david nutt
um a distinguished psychopharmacologist
uh who's many of work i've read
he's early staff we've mystic present
glue
his latest book drugs without the hot
tear is actually unflinching very honest
and very
evidence-rich accounts of what we need
to know about substances
coming from a different angle however is
admiring ward now anne-marie is the
founder of
a charity called fever which i
understand stands for um
faces and voices of recovery annery
herself is no stranger to substances and
22 years ago when she managed to say no
to them forever
she decided to start spreading the word
about what we can do in society to do
things
a little more sensibly when it comes to
trying to beat one's addictions
and then in the other corner we have
with dr pista shusted h
uh he's an angus gay and asian
philosopher who's got a particular
interest in the works
of whitehead and of nietzsche and uh
who also has a interest in fields of pan
sacrificing and
quite a few other ideas and interests
besides majority of people who use
illegal drugs to deal with
well i i think firstly i would say that
the concept of recreational drugs is
that's almost the term recreation is
almost stigmatizing in itself
because many of the drugs which people
supposedly used as recreational drugs
are used to treat
suffering majority of people who use
illegal drugs are
using them to deal with problems of life
they're not actually having fun with
them so that's the first thing
the supposition it's all about hedonism
is completely wrong
the second thing i would say is that the
attempt to
stop people using them is generally
misguided and it's usually driven by a
theory that
these drugs in the long term will we
will lead to
tolerance dependence and a greater harm
unfortunately for a number of so-called
recreational drugs particularly
psychedelics that is completely
false in fact these drugs do not cause
tolerance or dependence
if anything they're anti-addictive and
that's why they're being resurrected on
my group and others now as potential
therapies for disorders such as
depression
and addiction but resurrecting drugs
out of the holes they've been put into
by the war on drugs the the intensely
uh severe scheduling of these drugs
makes it almost impossible for their
true value in medicine to
ever be realized so there's a lot to say
about it and i think you know
my own view is that many of these
so-called recreational drugs
are medicines which need to be liberated
not just to treat um mental illness but
also disorders such as pain
and potentially headaches as well thank
you david
uh and marie what's your pitch thanks
very much mark i don't think
professor not and i are diametrically
opposed at
all and i think it's um
drug use isn't a single human experience
and it might be useful to consider under
three separate headings
such as in problematic use
and addiction and using drugs to cope
with psychological or emotional
and even physical pain and three a
recreational drug user going back to
problematic drug use and addiction is
which is where i have the most
experience
personally and as a person in long-term
recovery
obviously that led and can lead to for
many people a range of physical
mental health problems and obviously
death
and it affects the lives of family
friends and the wider community in a
negative
negative way so it does undermine the
human experience without a doubt
but the second sort of uh
area there you know using drugs to cope
with psychological and emotional
physical
pain well this is a completely rational
human response
to the problem uh things like
bereavement relationship breakdowns are
universal human experiences that are
part of the natural cycle of life
and and you know that's that's always
going to be
um a way that human beings cope
uh and and what clue you know whatever
traumas in front of them
but i would still argue that it does
undermine the human experience and that
you're not getting to
experience the depth and of that pain
and three recreational drug use which is
often justified on the ground so it
enhances the human experience
you know for sex for socializing
for eating you know there's a hedonistic
neural response
and and obviously after prolonged use in
a long way dependency
many would argue that these things are
meant to be enjoyed
in a natural state so i don't think
professor knott and i
um are too diametrically opposed there i
think we would agree on a lot of
uh areas emery thank you very much
peter over to you what's your pitch um
well i
generally think that so-called
recreational drugs are beneficial
um in a number of ways i mean um so i'm
a philosopher
and i do uh of course see the medicinal
value that
david and anne-marie have spoken about
of course there are dangers there as
well such as painting patenting
and taking away the total value of
especially psychedelics
from other benefits such as
um well i'm a philosopher of mine so for
me psychedelic drugs especially
are very beneficial in terms of
augmenting
our phenomenological uh repository as it
were so um
you know much of the study of the mind
has been uh based on our prosaic forms
of consciousness
consciousness that we humans have
evolved and i think there's so much more
uh to be discovered than that which we
have even concepts for
so um these drugs certainly benefit
the academic study of that they also
benefit of course
our understanding of this this giant
mystery that
that everyone's speaking about really at
least my words which is
the mind matter mystery her mind and
mata relate um so
psychedelics give us indications uh
new neural correlations of consciousness
i remember david nutt once actually said
that
if you want to understand consciousness
you've got to study psychedelics
so these are perhaps pivotal in our in
the general philosophic psychological
um medical phenomenological mystery that
is consciousness and matter
um they also say a lot about you know
very specific philosophical issues such
as intentionality and access
consciousness and so on
um also in terms of metaphysics you know
the general big questions of the cosmos
i think
um again psychedelic drugs can offer so
much for example
um you know um you know one of the
one of the main philosophers in the
western canon spinoza speaks about
something
he calls the intellectual love of god
and for him god is nature
and it's this kind of punitive
experience a bit of a it's a bit of a
mystery to most readers but
perhaps psychedelics can offer a sort of
empirical clue to what he means you know
at least at the very least there's a lot
of um interesting metaphysical logical
work to be done there um
i think also with regard to white
whitehead's process philosophy am i
going over three minutes
well david yes something you're heading
in that direction yeah let's let's just
wind up there because i'm sure you'll
find
many chances to insert any other points
of view that you have so let's we can if
we may just
press on to the first issue of the
debate i want us to first consider this
question
do drugs actually undermine our
well-being as human beings do they take
something away from their existence
now we know that a lot of people always
huxley for example have argued very
passionately
in favor of the the enhancing scenes of
effective drugs and
alcohol kind of speaks for itself in
terms of ubiquity of use but
i wonder peter can i ask you what you
think the advantages might be
of well-being um for drugs
recreationally
for our well-being is a race well i
think um i mean
the first thing i'd i'd say qualify that
question with is um you know the uh
what we mean by well-being because this
might differ through culture and through
time
um but let's just take a general sort of
consensus that is
you know western european today um
i mean there's a lot of i mean the other
two will
know more about this than than i do but
um there's a lot of
evidence showing that uh psychedelics
again uh
psilocybin for example can treat
depression there's a trial going on
which has been improved officially uh at
the moment
um so in that sense i think mdma for
ptsd is being
researched at the moment and ketamine
and so on there's a lot of medical
benefits to it i think in terms
generally um
i mean i always see psychedelics as
almost like another
um facet to life so it
you know we can appreciate music one can
appreciate fine foods one can appreciate
landscape the open ocean or whatever i
think psychedelics
are are analogous to that they give
another facet to the enrichment of life
and for someone who has never had such
um an experience such as like a heavy
psychedelic experience
um they it's it to me it's a bit like us
a person missing out on the joy of music
or something like that
sometimes of well-being that alone i
think
um is a uh a pointer towards their
benefits emery what do you make of that
well i'm reflecting on my own experience
of psychedelics really and
i had a very positive experience with
psychedelics as a young woman
and to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas